The Joe Rogan Experience I do have an
opinion on algorithms and I do have an
opinion on what it does do to young
girls self-esteem and you have teenage
daughters yes I just think I mean in
young girls are a point of focus for
why their point of focus more than young
boys I'm not entirely sure I guess it
has to do with their emotional makeup
and and there's higher risk of self-harm
due to social media and Jonathan hate
talked about that in his book The
coddling of the American mind
um it's it's very clear that it's very
damaging and I my kids uh you know my 13
year old does have like interactions
with their friends and I do see how they
bully each other and talk [ __ ] about
each other and it's it's they get so
angry and mad at each other
um it is a factor but it's a it's an
algorithm issue right
it's there's multiple things here so the
first thing is
um just to kind of set the stage a
little bit uh I always use EO Wilson the
sociobiologist who who uh sort of
defined what what the problem statement
for Humanity is he said the fundamental
problem of humanity is we have
Paleolithic emotions and brains like
easy brains that are hackable for
magicians we have medieval institutions
you know government that's not really
good at seeing the latest tech whether
it was railroads or now social media or
AI or deep fakes or whatever is coming
next and then we have god-like
technology so we have Paleolithic
emotions medieval institutions god-like
technology you combine that fact that's
the fundamental problem statement how do
we wield the power of gods without the
love prudence and wisdom of gods there's
actually something that Daniel taught me
and
um then you add to that the race to the
bottom of the brain stem for attention
what is their business model just to
review the basics everybody knows this
now but it's it's engagement it's like
how do I get that attention at all costs
yeah so algorithms is one piece of that
meaning
um when you're on a news feed like I
don't want to just show you any news I
want to show you the most viral engaging
like longest argumentative comment
threads news right so that's like
pointing a trillion dollar market cap AI
at your brain saying I'm going to show
you the next perfect Boogeyman for your
nervous system the thing that's going to
make you upset angry whether it's masks
vaccines Francis Haugen whatever the
thing is it will just drive that over
and over again and then repeat that
thing and that's one of the the tools in
the Arsenal to get attention is that the
algorithms another one is technology
making design decisions like how do we
inflate people's sense of uh
beautification filters in fact just
recently since we talked last time
um I think it's a MIT tech review
article showing that um they're all
they're all competing first of all to
like inflate your sense of beauty so
they're doing the the I think
people know this stuff it's very obvious
but they're competing for who can give
you a nicer filter right and then now
instead of waiting for you to actually
add one Tick Tock was actually found to
actually do like a two percent like just
bare beautification filter on the no
filter mode because the thing is once
they do that the other guys have to do
it too so I just want to name that all
of this is taking place in this race to
capture human attention because if I
don't do it the other guy will and then
it's happening with design decisions
like the beautification filters and like
the follow you and if you follow me I'll
follow you back in the like button and
check pull to refresh the dopamine stuff
that's all design then there's the
algorithms which is I'm pointing at a
thing at your brain to figure out what
how can I show you an infinite feed that
just maximally enrages you and we should
talk about that because that thing
drives polarization which breaks
democracy but that's a that's a we can
get into that oh Daniel let's bring you
in here so how did you guys uh meet and
how did this uh sort of
dynamic duo come about yeah I was
working on studying kind of catastrophic
risks writ large you've had people on
the show talking about risks associated
with AI and with crispr and genetic
engineering and with climate change and
environmental issues and pull up to the
microphone there and there you go
escalation Pathways to war and all these
kinds of things and basically how can it
depend right
and I think it's a pretty common
question of like how long do we have on
which of these and are we doing a good
job of tending to them so that we get to
solve the rest of them and then for me
it was there were so many of them what
was in common driving them are there any
kind of like societal generator
functions of all the catastrophic risks
that we can address with to make a more
uh resilient civilization writ large
Tristan was working on the social media
issues and
um when you had Eric on he talked about
the twin nuclei problem of atomic energy
and kind of genetic engineering and
basically saying these are extremely
powerful technologies that we don't have
the wisdom to Steward that power well
well in addition to that is all things
computation does right there's a few
other major categories and computation
has the ability to as as you mentioned
with Facebook get to billions of people
in a very very short period of time
compared to how quickly the railroads
expanded or like any other type of tech
get to a billion people a billion users
which they did in like a few years
versus before that it took software
companies like Microsoft even longer
than that before that took railroads
even longer than that so the power of
this Tech is you can compress the
timeline so you're getting you know a
scale of a billion people's uh you're
impacting a billion people in deeper
ways much faster which means that if
you're blind to something if you don't
know what you might be doing the
consequences show up faster than you can
actually remediate them when we say
exponential Tech we mean a number of
things we mean Tech that makes more
powerful versions of itself so I can use
computer chips to model how to make
better computer chips and then those
better computer chips can recursively do
that we also mean exponential speed of
impact exponential scale of impact
exponentially more Capital return Burns
exponentially smaller numbers of people
capable of achieving a scale of impact
and so when he's mentioning god-like
powers and kind of medieval institutions
the speed at which our Tech is having
influences in the world and not just
first order influences the obvious stuff
but the second and third order ones
Facebook isn't trying to polarize the
population it's an externality it's a
side effect of the thing they're trying
to do which is to optimize ad Revenue
but the speed at which new technologies
are having effects on the world and the
total amount of consequence is way
faster than regulation can keep up with
and just by that alone we should be
skeptical of any government's ability to
regulate something that's moving faster
than it faster than it can appraise of
what the hell is even happening in the
first place not only that you need
someone who really understands the
technology and you're not going to get
that from elected officials you're going
to need someone who's working on it and
has a comprehensive understanding of how
the stuff works how it's engineered
where it goes you're I mean I'm
skeptical of the government being able
to regulate almost everything